because this is what they would do I
remember my roommates he would sit on my
face wash your face down here because
I'm on the ground and you will sit on
and then he will slap me like this for
like what's he went 15 minutes wait if
he's sitting on your face what's he
slapping like my chest sounds like it's
a white boy [ __ ] was he white no he was
like is he punking in for reals or is he
showing you like love that specific was
talking to me for real I was just like
stop
he was my roommate he was a junior I was
in eighth grade he was like my platoon
Sergeant it was love after though he
showed me like 50 Cent you know and I
was like he said
I know he said in your face but check
this out Get Rich or Die try it I I was
really sad because people would keep on
bullying me and it would keep showing
you 50 cents every time
a new artist afterwards yeah that's how
he learns about hip-hop and he'll be
happy who's Fat Joe they're just running
out of him all right here's some
independent dude we're running out bro